For some reason, for some reason
I
'm my older sister
Sometimes when I'm helpless at home, I'm a dwarf, a
very dirty person
I don't know why, but
there are times when I feel that way,
there are times when I can only think so
There is, but at times like that, I always feel that other things,
such as
the way other people live in the world, are all beautiful and wonderful
.
As long
as I'm traveling, I'm sure there's a lot of hard things
and sad things lying around wherever I go.
It's
fun to do, and even if I have to kill people, I
want to keep doing it.
Yes, I think it's okay Yes,
maybe I myself don't understand well Maybe I'm
lost
And maybe I'm continuing my journey to understand more
Tatami
I'm going to sleep I'll see you tomorrow  I have to run
Sumiya
Good night function